wenn schwester wäre dient zur arbeit
ruft ist aber zur stelle
heute wartet auf den jungen iraker
gartenarbeit die tägliche beschäftigung
im klosterhof hilft ihnen die angst vor
einer abschiebung zu vergessen denn
eigentlich müsste der angehörige der
jüdischen minderheit zurück nach
rumänien weil er dort die eu betreten
hatte so verlangen es die eu abkommen
doch dort soll er von der polizei
misshandelt worden sein
ich wünschte ich könnte das
klostergelände als freier mensch
verlassen ohne fürchten zu müssen dass
mich dann sofort die polizei festnimmt
und mich wieder zurückschickt doch
hinter den mauern des
dominikanerinnenkloster sind hermann und
die fünf anderen kirchenasyl flüchtlinge
sicher vorerst jedenfalls
hier bekommen sie von den schwestern
nicht nur essen und unterkunft sondern
auch jeden nachmittag deutschunterricht
und fordere
früher bekamen abgelehnte asylbewerber
die sich wie harman danach in eine
kirche flüchteten fast immer die chance
einer zweiten anhörung
doch das scheint vorbei das zuständige
bundesamt lehnt neuerdings fast alle
anträge ab die verschärfung des
kirchenasyls stellt die
klostergemeinschaft vor zusätzliche
probleme
schwester geraldine war es oft nicht wie
lange die schützlinge bei ihr bleiben
müssen und sie muss manchmal hilfe
suchen der flüchtlinge ab weisen das ist
als die asylsuchenden auch selber
hierher kamen am boden zerstört und vor
mir lag denn weinten und wenn ich dann
sagen musste wir haben keinen platz wir
haben schon so viele und es geht nicht
mehr
da habe ich gedacht mein gott das ist
vielleicht das kannst du nicht immer aus
dem fernen berlin stößt so viel
christliche nächstenliebe bei ihnen
politikern auf skepsis
man werde das kirchenasyl respektieren
und niemanden mit polizeigewalt
herausholen aber rechtsfreie räume
würden nicht toleriert
auch im kirchenasyl kann es nur das
zusätzliche recht einer überprüfung
geben dass man automatisch dem anliegen
der kirchengemeinden recht gibt ist doch
eine völlig falsche vorstellung das wäre
in einem rechtsstaat absolut nicht
akzeptabel
und das setzt schwester geraldine unter
druck sie sucht den kontakt zu anderen
der landesweit rund 450 gemeinden mit
kirchenasyl
gemeinsam wollen sie sich dagegen wehren
dass ein flüchtling neuerdings
mindestens 18 monate in den
kirchenräumen leben muss denn die
ausweisung verhindert werden soll
denn erst dann ist die frist zur
abschiebung in einen anderen eu-staat
für flüge nach abgelaufen wenn die
diesen brief erhalten also ihre frist
hat sich auf 18 monate verlängert die
meisten fallen ihnen ein doch ist auch
schon mal so dass jemand gesagt hat ich
hau' ab ich suche mir ein anderes land
manche haben wir dich erst mal eine
längere depression wirklich ich selber
finde es sehr bedauerlich dass wir in
einem demokratischen rechtsstaat derzeit
sehr viel kirchen dass viele machen
müssen aber auch der rechtsstaat ist
nicht unfehlbar
wir haben neulich ein hoher richter
selber gesagt wir brauchen kirchen das
will weil wir ich das sind auch nicht
unfehlbar und da gibt es dann gewiss das
100 ihres korrektiv während sein
jüngerer bruder asyl schutz bekommen hat
und in der nächsten kleinstadt zur
schule gehen kann muss hamann im kloster
weiter warten
wenn er mit seinen eltern und
geschwistern im irak spricht dann macht
er sich ständig sorgen
vor fünf jahren wurden rund 7000 frauen
und kinder von der terrorgruppe es im
irak fast klafft viele seiner
jesidischen verwandten wurden getötet
schwester geraldine will standhaft
bleiben für sie ist klar hamann und ihre
anderen schützlinge dürfen solange im
kloster bleiben bis sich eine lösung
gefunden hat der lite da was ihr dem
geringsten meiner brüder getan habt das
habt ihr mir getan das ist
wir sagen immer wir
nach den werten des evangeliums und das
ist dann eigentlich neue praxis
umgesetzt
harman ist kein christ aber in die
klosterkapelle zieht es ihn immer wieder
aus dankbarkeit und bewunderung denn er
weiß ohne den festen glauben der
ordensschwestern wäre er vermutlich
nicht mehr in deutschland